i'm not leaving my family
[Music]
what time is it it's early
i got jessie fed i'll get her to school
you sure yeah what you want
you got him okay
antonio leblanc how you get a last name
like that
i was adopted is that where you were
today
yeah bye oh nothing it's a good choice
come on let's go
[Music]
where are you from uh i'm from about
hour north of baton rouge
where are you from like born i was born
in korea
i got this baby on the way and i'm just
looking for another job
kathy hey where you going what's going
home here
hey listen now you're okay let's go hey
did i say you can leave
stop i'm gonna tell you one last
i posted bail he should have been out by
now he's not here anymore
i stuck him what
[Music]
i just don't understand how they can
deport him i was brought here when i was
three
can't we do something about this i mean
listen to him look at him he's american
ice is talking to people like you
adopted or not i've been here for over
30 years
you also have a criminal record
[Music]
bro come on what's going on i usually
charge 5 000 to start
are you getting kicked out not baby girl
i ain't going to win yo antonio
you know the drill bro
you know i'd cover the moon with your
right
i ain't scared you can
depart voluntarily or you can stay
and appeal but if the judge don't rule
in your favor
he can never come back
[Music]
i'm not leaving my family
[Music]
you